What do you think about Adhd?
I have it.
I'm frustrated by my failures in life because of it.
I am trying to become a a chemist and I am failing at school.
Um,
I think ADHD is a catch all diagnosis.
I think that people who are extroverted and unconscientious for example,
often manifest the traits of,
of uh,
attention deficit disorder.
Um,
I know that there isn't any real evidence of longterm utility and cycle and
cycle.
What a psycho pharmacological treatment for Adhd.
Um,
I would say though,
if you are having a hard time concentrating on your goals,
that what you should probably do is set yourself up with a therapist,
find someone you can talk to,
you know,
so see two or three therapists.
I know it's expensive but so is not having a life.
Find someone you can talk to and then make it and someone practical,
probably a behavioral therapist would be best.
And then have them set goals with you and help you strategize to stay on track
week to week.
That's the best thing.
Or to set that up with a friend if he can't do it with the therapist.
So that's,
that's the best advice I have for that.
And keep at it,
man.
You know,
but break your,
you gotta learn to schedule.
You got to learn to break your days down into disciplined subsections and you've
got to practice out at and practice at it.
And,
um,
there isn't an easier answer that I know of,
but having someone that will help keep your responsible,
I think can be useful.
I've seen that be useful for people who have attention deficits,
disorder,
let's say.